somebody has to pay for that and it's
falling back on either Amazon or the
third party seller 161 billion dollars
worth of merchandise was returned
it's no secret that people aren't
exactly fans of big Tech they don't like
Facebook they don't like Google and they
especially don't like Amazon usually the
primary critique against Amazon is the
way they run their business Amazon has
become infamous for Cutthroat rules and
a miserable working conditions their
drivers often have to be in bottles
while their warehouse workers are often
left with a chronic pain this is why
many Amazon warehouses have turnover
rates that are over 100 percent Amazon
hasn't never really worried too much
about this as they found that high
turnover is actually a good thing at
warehouses it turns out that people are
usually more motivated and productive
when they get a new warehouse job than
they are a few months in so it's
actually an Amazon's best interest to
keep things churning at as long as
there's enough people to turn through of
course hearing all this I'm sure most of
you have some level of distaste for the
meat grinder that is Amazon but many of
our peers have actually been taking this
distaste to the next level they're not
just complaining about it on the
Internet or advocating for unions
instead they're actually stealing from
it and defrauding Amazon the worst
offenders rack up a stolen merchandise
in the hundreds of thousands of dollars
and even over a million dollars while
these are the people who make it onto
the news there are tens of thousands and
maybe even hundreds of thousands of
everyday people who are pulling off the
same scam on a much smaller basis these
guys usually have 500 or a thousand
dollars worth of stolen merchandise so
here's exactly how people have been
stealing at billions from one of the
largest companies in the world
foreign
isn't all that hard to understand
essentially people have been abusing at
Amazon's generous return policy to get
unjustified refunds on products while
simple in nature there's actually a
bunch of nuances that are involved in
making this cam work because Amazon is
of course not stupid they're well aware
of this game and they're constantly
tightening their procedures and
protocols to minimize its occurrence
nonetheless many everyday people are
still benefiting from this gamut thanks
to the existence of full-on scam
businesses I'm sure you've heard about
the classic gift cards cameras that will
email you or call you pretending to be
an apple Amazon or Microsoft they'll
usually tell you that your computer has
some sort of virus and that you need to
pay them in the form of gift cards to
fix it if you're interested in the inner
workings of these scams I would
recommend that you check out Jim Brown's
videos on them but anyway some of these
cameras have switched strategies instead
of scamming Everyday People they've
pivoted to helping everyday people scam
Amazon usually they'll set up a Discord
Community that's filled with a couple of
scammers then they'll go out and
discreetly promote their servers online
really they don't need that much
attention they just need 5 or 10 people
to join up from there these servers
usually grow through Word of Mouth once
these 5 or 10 people get products for a
super low price they often tell their
friends about it and within no time
these servers end up boasting it
thousands of users all these users have
to do it is tell the scammers what
product they want and those cameras will
get it for them for a 70 or 80 discount
if you were to do this this cameras will
start off by creating a fake Amazon
account on your behalf from there you'll
use gift cards or stolen credit cards to
order a bunch of merchandise to an
Airbnb or some sort of temporary address
nowadays almost all the couriers take
pictures of the delivered products so
these cameras are often made to delivers
outside the Airbnb and prevent them from
taking a picture this makes it as
especially easy for them to turn around
and convince Amazon that their product
was never delivered and get a refund
from there they'll ship it to the
Discord member who requested their
product and this cameras will keep the
20 or 30 percent that the members did
pay this strategy generally only works
on cheaper products though when it comes
to more expensive products these cameras
have to turn to a different strategy the
first part of this camel works exactly
the same they'll use a fake account and
fake credentials to order a product but
this time they won't try to convince
Amazon that the product wasn't delivered
instead they'll take the product replace
it with their Fair counterfeit and
return it this scheme is especially
common with Apple's airpods Max the
sticker price of the headphones is 550
dollars but you can buy an extremely
convenient replica for just 120 on
Alibaba which is about 22 of the price
this gives the scammers plenty of margin
to give the Discord member a 60 or a 70
discount and that's exactly how they
pull off this scam
foreign
this Camp has exploded in popularity
especially amongst college students and
the broke young adults but for obvious
reasons engaging in this game is a
horrible idea first of all there's the
whole moral dilemma you're essentially
stealing products from Amazon and or
Amazon sellers given that most people go
to Discord scammers and get them to do
the Dirty Work This is obviously not
something that they're willing to do
themselves and if you can tell that
something is unethical to do yourself
you probably shouldn't not be getting
someone else to do it for you some of
these people like to argue that they're
just getting back at the evil trillion
dollar corporation that is Amazon but
this is just an excuse to justify their
actions really they're not getting back
at Amazon at all if anything they're
making the lives of Amazon employees
even worse here's the thing what do you
think Amazon is going to do it if a
delivery driver racks up a record of
quote-unquote Lost deliveries they're
obviously going to fire them not to
mention the cost of stolen products
usually ends up coming out of the
paychecks of Amazon employees while
Amazon gets a lot of slack for not
paying employees enough the truth isn't
that Amazon doesn't want to pay
employees more it's that they simply
cannot afford to pay more yes Jeff Bezos
is one of the richest people in the
world but all of that is stock value
when it comes to actual cash flow Amazon
literally has negative cash flow for
decades they've been using AWS to
subsidize their retail business which
has basically never been profitable with
that being said though Amazon has never
placed right for profitability either
they'd rather just maintain a break-even
income statement and reinvest everything
into new warehouses Logistics channels
and of course employees and the people
who are stealing from Amazon are
directly preventing this from happening
now you may not think that this would
make that big of a difference but that's
completely Falls in 2021 a record 761
billion dollars worth of merchandise was
returned and out of this a whopping 10.3
percent of returns were fraudulent that
translates to 78.3 billion dollars every
single year and it that's just the ones
that are caught the good scams go
completely undetected so the percentage
of fraudulent returns is probably closer
to 15 or 20 percent but even if we
assume a 10 this works out to billions
of dollars per year for Amazon alone the
average Amazon return rate stands at 5
to 15 percent depending on the category
and season we can just estimate in the
middle and to call it 10 if 10 percent
of Amazon orders are returned and 10 of
those returns are fraudulent Amazon is
being defrauded on roughly one percent
of their top line revenue in 2021 Amazon
had net sales of 279 billion in North
America and a 127 billion dollars
internationally which adds up to a total
of 406 billion dollars now that net
sales meaning that it already accounts
for the revenue loss due to returns this
means that their Top Line number was
roughly 450 billion dollars using our
fraud estimate of a one percent Amazon
lost approximately 4.5 billion dollars
last year due to return fraud and stolen
goods and there's only two ways that
Amazon can pay for this they can either
increase prices or decrease salaries
given their history we know that they'd
rather decrease salaries than increased
prices currently Amazon has a total of
1.6 million employees if this money had
gone towards their paychecks each and
every one of them could have earned an
extra 2 800 last year and it's not just
Amazon employees that are being hurt
either random customers and sellers are
also feeling the pain first of all some
random person is going to become a
victim of a credit card fraud after that
once the douchebags camera Returns the
fake pair of airpods Max it's more than
likely that some other Amazon customer
is going to end up with that junk even
though they pay the full 550 dollars
when they realize this they're gonna
have to call it Amazon and explain the
situation and Amazon it's probably going
to turn around it and flag the seller's
account and the customer will probably
go leave a terrible review if this
happens a few times Amazon will probably
ban the seller thinking that there are
counterfeit product seller so in the end
you're left with Amazon employees who
are getting the short end of the stick
yeah victims of credit card fraud you
have customers with fake products and a
nightmare buying experience and you have
a seller who just lost their small
business and all of this is just so that
some broke losers across the country can
Flex to their friends with products that
they can't afford when you think about
it it's really quite messed up
to make things worse this scam is no
longer unique to Amazon virtually every
retailer has gotten into the online game
and they're all dealing with the same
issue whether it be best to buy or Gucci
This scam is even starting to spread it
into other Industries such as Grocery
and food delivery this server for
example is offering 80 off on grocery
delivery and at 55 off on food delivery
to accomplish this this cameras just
charge the entire amount onto a stolen
credit card number and it's up to their
fraud victim to file for credit card
fraud and get a refund usually the
refund is issued by the credit card
company or the food delivery app
fortunately the delivery driver still
gets paid for the delivery even if the
order is refunded in most cases but once
again someone has to pay for this
generally this just leads to higher
prices across food delivery apps and the
apps taking a larger portion of the
revenue from both the restaurant and the
driver if the credit card company runs
the cost you have a similar conundrum
they're gonna try to make this money
back by raising their 23 interest rates
to 25 and given that the average
American has nearly six thousand dollars
in credit card debt these cameras aren't
doing the country any flavors and the
worst part about all of this is that
this camera is only possible because of
us traditional scams just require a
scammer and a victim but this camera
requires a scammer a victim and a
customer without a customer it cannot
operate and these customers aren't
random people in developing countries
these customers are our neighbors our
classmates our friends and it might even
be you also it's not like these people
are stealing for survival either after
all they're not stealing a loaf of bread
or eggs instead they're stealing high
value Tech products like computers
laptops and phones or they're stealing
convenient services that they don't want
to pay for like food and grocery
delivery and in the end how can we
honestly criticize these big tech
companies and evil businesses when many
of our peers are engaging in the same
activities when given the opportunity
now I'm not suggesting that we should
just let the big companies off the hook
I'm just suggesting that we should try
to clean up our side as well but that's
just what I think were you familiar with
this cam comment that down below also
drop a like if you hope that people wise
up sooner rather than later and of
course consider checking out our Discord
Community suggested video ideas and
consider subscribing to see more
questions logically answered but until
then I'm Hari and I'll see you guys on
the next one
[Music]
foreign